in this video we'll talk about the
second major type of machine learning
problem called unsupervised learning in
the last video we talked about
supervised learning back then we count
data sets that look like this where each
example was labeled either as a positive
or a negative example whether it was a
benign or a malignant tumor so for each
example in supervised learning we were
told explicitly what is the so-called
right answer whether it's benign or
malignant in unsupervised learning we're
given data that looks different in green
data that looks like this that doesn't
have any labels or that of all has the
same label or really no labels so we're
given the data set and we're not told
what to do a bit and we're not told what
each data point is instead we just told
here is a data set can you find some
structure in the data given this data
set an unsupervised learning algorithm
might decide that the data lives in two
different clusters so there's one
cluster and there's a different cluster
and the unsupervised learning algorithm
may break this data into these two
separate clusters so this is called a
clustering algorithm and this turns out
to be used in many places one example
where clustering is used is in Google
News and if you're not seeing this
before you can actually go to this URL
news.google.com to take a look what
Google News does is every day it goes
and looks at tens of thousands or
hundreds of thousands of new stories on
the web and it groups them into cohesive
news stories for example let's look here
the URLs here link to different news
stories about the BP oil well story so
let's say I click on one of these URLs
and I click on one of these URLs what
I'll get to is a web page like this
here's a Wall Street Journal article
about you know the BP oil wells still
stories of BP cause Macondo which is the
name of the un-- scope and if you click
on a different URL from that group then
you might get the different story
she's a CNN story about again the BP oil
spill and if you click on get a third
link that you might get
a different story here's the UK Guardian
story about the BP oil spill so a Google
News is done is looked at tens of
thousands of new stories and
automatically cluster them together so
the new stories that are all about the
same topic get to display together it
turns out that clustering algorithms and
unsupervised learning algorithms are
used in many other problems as well
here's one on understanding genomics
here's an example of DNA microarray data
the idea is you have a group of
different individuals and for each of
them you measure how much they do or do
not have a certain gene technically you
measure how much of certain genes are
expressed so these colors red green gray
and so on they show the degree to which
different individuals do or do not have
a specific gene and what you can do is
then run a clustering algorithm to group
individuals into different categories
onto different types of people so this
is unsupervised learning because we're
not telling the algorithm in advance
that you know these are Taiwan people
those are type 2 persons those are type
3 persons and so on and instead what
we're saying is you know here's a bunch
of data I don't know what's in this data
I don't know who's in what type I didn't
know what the different types of people
are but can you automatically find
structure in the data from you
automatically cluster the individuals
into these types that I don't know in
advance because we're not giving them
the algorithm the right answer for the
examples in my data set this is
unsupervised learning unsupervised
learning or clustering is used for a
bunch of other applications is used to
organize large computer clusters I had
some friends looking at large data
centers that there's large computer
clusters and trying to figure out which
machines tend to work together and if
you can put those machines together you
can make your data center work more
efficiently your second application on
social network analysis so given
knowledge about which friends you email
the most or given your Facebook friends
or your Google+ Circles
can we automatically identify which are
cohesive groups of friends so what are
groups of people that all know each
other
market segmentation many companies have
huge databases of customer information
so can you look at this customer data
set and automatically discover market
segments and automatically group your
customers into different market segments
so that you can automatically and more
efficiently sell or market to your
different market segments together again
this is unsupervised learning because we
have all this customer data but we don't
know in advance what are the market
segments and for the customers in our
data set you know we don't know in
advance who is in microsecond one who is
in market segments two and so on but we
have to let the algorithm discover all
this just from the data finally it turns
out that unsupervised learning is also
used for surprisingly astronomical data
analysis and these clustering algorithms
give surprisingly interesting or useful
theories of how galaxies are formed all
these are examples of clustering which
is just one type of unsupervised
learning let me tell you about another
one I'm going to tell you about the
cocktail party problem so we've been the
cocktail parties before right where you
can imagine there's a party room for
people all sitting around all talk at
the same time and there are all these
overlapping voices because everyone's
talked in the same time and it's almost
hard to hear the person in front of you
so maybe have a cocktail party with two
people two people talking the same time
and someone small cocktail party and
we're going to put two microphones in
the room so there are microphones and
because these microphones are at two
different distances from the speaker's
each microphone records a different
combination of these two speakers voices
maybe speaker one is a little louder in
microphone one and maybe speaker two is
a little bit louder in microphone two
because you know the two microphones are
at different positions relative to the 2
speakers but each microphone recalls an
overlapping combination of both speakers
voices
so here's an here's an actual recording
two speakers recorded by a researcher
let me play for you the first one the
first microphone sounds like one two
three one my head alright maybe not the
most interesting cocktail party is two
people counting from one to ten in two
languages that you know there you go
what you just heard was the first
microphone recording here's the second
recording you see the names so we can do
is take these two microphone recordings
and give them to an unsupervised
learning algorithm called the cocktail
party algorithm and tell the algorithm
find structure in this data for me and
what the album will do is listen to
these audio recordings and say you know
it sounds like the two audio recordings
that being added together or there being
some together to produce these
recordings that we had moreover what the
cocktail party algorithm will do is
separate out these two audio sources
that were being added or being summed
together to form our recordings and in
fact here's the first output of the
cocktail party algorithm one two three
oh five six seven eight nine ten so
separated out the English voice in one
of us in one of the recordings and
here's the second output uno dos tres
cuatro Cinco seis fifty all true really
it is not too bad to give you one more
example here's another recording of
another similar situation here's the
first microphone
okay so the poor guys gone home from the
cocktail party and he's now studying the
route by himself talking to his video he
has the second microphone recording
when you give these two microphone
recording to the same algorithm what it
does is again say you know it sounds
like there are two audio sources and
moreover the album says here is the
first of the audio sources
I found one two three four five six
seven eight nine ten so that wasn't
perfect it got the boys but they'll also
go up into the music in there then
here's the second output of the
algorithm
II not too bad in that second output and
managed to get rid of the voice entirely
and just Co cleaned up the music and got
rid of the counting from one to ten so
you might look at an unsupervised
learning algorithm like this and ask how
complicated is it to implement this it
seems like in order to you know build
this application it seems like to do
this
audio processing you need to write a ton
of code or maybe link into like a bunch
of C++ or Java libraries to process
audio it seems like an really
complicated program to do this audio
separating out audio and so on
it turns out the algorithm to do what
you just heard that can be done with one
line of code shown right here it did
take me searches a long time to come up
with this line of code so I'm not saying
this is an easy problem but it turns out
that we use the right programming
environment many learning algorithms can
be really short programs so this is also
why in this class we're going to use the
octave programming environment octave is
free open source software and using a
tool like octave or MATLAB many learning
algorithms become just a few lines of
code to implement later in this class
also teach you a little bit about how to
use octave and you'll be implementing
some of these albums in octave or if you
have MATLAB you can use that - turns out
that Silicon Valley for a lot of machine
learning algorithms what we do is first
prototype our software in octave because
software that octave makes it incredibly
fast implement these learning algorithms
here are each of these functions like
for example the SVD function that sends
the singular value decomposition but
that turns out to be a linear algebra
routine that is just built into octave
if you were trying to do this a C++ or
Java this would be many many lines of
code linking complex C++ or Java
libraries so you can implement this
stuff in C++ or Java or Python there's
just much more complicated to use to do
some of those languages what I've seen
after having taught machine learning for
almost about a decade now is that you
learn much faster if you use octave as
your programming environment and if you
use octave as your learning tool and as
your prototyping tool I'll let you learn
and prototype learning
rooms much more quickly and in fact what
many people will do in the large Silicon
Valley companies is in fact use an
algorithm like octave to first prototype
the learning algorithm and only after
you've gotten to where and then you
migrate it to C++ or Java or whatever it
turns out that by doing things this way
you can often get your algorithm to work
much faster than if you were starting
out in C++ so I know that this instruct
as an instructor I get to say trust me
on this one only a finite number of
times but for those of you who have
never used these octave type programming
environments before I'm going to answer
there trust me on this one and say that
you you will I think your time when you
develop a time is one of the most
valuable resources and having seen lots
of people do this I think you as a
machine learning researcher or machine
learning developer will be much more
productive if you learn to stuff in
prototype to stuff in octave and in some
of the language finally to wrap up this
video have one quick review question for
you we talked about unsupervised
learning which is the learning setting
where you give the algorithm a ton of
data and just ask it to find structure
in the data for us of the following four
examples which ones which of these four
do you think would be an unsupervised
learning out algorithm as opposed to a
supervised learning problem for each of
the four check boxes on the Left check
the ones or which you think of
unsupervised learning algorithm would be
appropriate and then click the button on
the lower right to check your answer so
when the video pauses please answer the
question on the slide so hopefully
remember the spam filter problem if you
have labeled data you know with of spam
and non-spam email we treat this as a
supervised learning problem the new
story example that's exactly the Google
News example that we saw in this video
we saw how you can use a clustering
algorithm to cluster news articles
together so that's unsurprising learning
the market segmentation example I talked
a little bit earlier do that as an
unsupervised learning problem because
I'm just going to give my
from data and ask you to discover market
segments automatically and the final
example diabetes well that's actually
just like our breast cancer example from
the last video
only instead of you know good and bad
cancer tumors or benign and malignant
tumors we instead have have diabetes or
not and so we will use that as a
supervised we will solve that as a
supervised learning problem just like we
did for the breast tumor data so that's
it for unsupervised learning and in the
next video we'll delve more into
specific learning algorithms and start
to talk about just how these algorithms
work and how we can how you can go about
implementing them